day one of cooking comfort food from
every country starting off with the call
a comfort food from my home country of
Vietnam
I hold this recipe so close to my heart
because it was the first dish that I
learned to cook to impress my mom to
marinate the pork belly I added brown
sugar fish sauce soy sauce garlic and
shallots I like to use hard-boiled quail
eggs but you can use chicken eggs if you
want since it's more traditional every
family has their own recipe and every
family believes theirs is the most
Superior including me oh that was
satisfying caramelizing the sugar is the
most difficult part about this dish but
it's also the most crucial since it's
what gives this dish that rich
mouth-watering deep brown color I
remember eating this the most during fed
AKA Lunar New Year let me know which
comfort food I should make next